За інформацією Київводоканалу, вода, що подається в мережу Києва,
завжди відповідає державним санітарним нормам.
Про те, що можна пити воду з крана не раз заявляв і мер Києва Віталій Кличко.
Втім, кияни часто скаржаться на погану якість води,
на те, що вона каламутна та має неприємний запах.
За даними Київводоканалу, кияни щодня споживають до семисот мільйонів літрів води.
І аби потрапити в кран, вода подекуди долає близько чотирьох тисяч кілометрів.
Саме така довжина київських водопровідних мереж.
Головні ж джерела постачання води в столиці - це річки Дніпро,
Десна та - до 10% - артезіанські джерела.
Дивлячись на те, як щороку зеленіє вода в Дніпрі, страшно уявити, що саме її
споживають містяни.  DW вирішила перевірити якість води з крана у Києві,
відправивши пробу науковим фахівцям. Воду набираємо в типовій багатоповерхівці,
зведеній вже в часи незалежності поблизу залізничного вокзалу.
За чотири дні лабораторія "Укрхіманаліз" має зробити повну діагностику
води з міського водопроводу.
Тим часом якість води в кранах регулярно перевіряють і лабораторії "Київводоканалу".
Щоправда, контролювати їх донедавна не було кому.
Раніше це зрідка робив Київський міський лабораторний центр.
Втім, з березня 2020 року, з початком пандемії COVID-19,  РНБО вирішила,
що воду слід перевіряти частіше і ретельніше.
Тож тепер забори відбуваються щотижня.
Є результати за цей поточний рік.
Ми відібрали всього 137 проб, за 2021 рік.
З них відхилень по централізованому водопостачанню (те, за що "Київводоканал"відповідає) було 31 відхилення,
з них 16 по бактеріях і 19 по санітарно-хімічних показниках.
З цих відхилень вода, що подавалась до будинків, лише 5 проб.
Інша вода з крана відбиралася, але не в фізичних осіб,
а в дитячих будинках,  садочках, таборах, промислових об'єктах.
Тож, як показує дана перевірка,
майже кожна п'ята проба не відповідає державним санітарним нормам.
Відхилення почали відбуватися з потеплінням - з травня по липень.
Саме в цей період кияни масово скаржились на те, що вода в крані рудого кольору
і має неприємний запах.
У "Київводоканалі" визнають існування цієї проблеми та пояснюють її
аномальним потеплінням та зміною клімату.
На сьогодні якість річок змінюється в гіршу сторону.
На Деснянських очисних спорудах доза когулянту завжди була 25-30 мг на літр,
а в цьому році доза 130.
Це свідчить про те, що забрудник збільшився і ми вимушені коригувати свої процеси,
збільшувати витрати на реагенти, щоб забезпечувати питною водою.
По Дніпру ще гірша ситуація.
Водопровідна система столиці закільцьована і змішування і очистка води відбувається
на двох очисних станціях - Дніпровській та Деснянській.
Вони збудовані ще за радянських часів.
Одній - понад вісімдесят років, іншій - шістдесят.
Вода на них очищається за традиційною технологією, що включає дві стадії хлорування
та відстоювання (фільтрування на піщаних фільтрах).
За весь час модернізовувалися певні споруди станцій, змінювалися
технічні процеси очистки води. Наприклад, на Дніпровській станції уже майже рік
для очистки води використовують діоксид хлору, що на відміну від хлору
забезпечує повну бактеріальну чистоту води.
Втім, цього не достатньо, і в самому водоканалі кажуть, що станції
потребують повного капітального ремонту.
Крім того, "Київводоканал" відповідає за якість води у так званих "контрольних точках",
місцях входу води в будинок. Далі відповідальність перекладається
на утримувачів будинків - ЖЕКи та ОСББ.
Саме через застарілу водопровідну систему будинку найчастіше і стаються
відхилення від норм, упевнені на підприємстві.
Розглядаючи скарги, які до нас надходять,
(безумовно,маємо інструкцію, алгоритм реагування на них ),
виїжджає лаборант,  ми відбираємо воду в 3 точках: на вході в будинок,
на першому поверсі і за тією адресою, де скаржаться.
І коли з'ясовується, що на вході в будинок вода нормативна,
а в квартирі вона гірша.
І тоді з'ясовують причину.
І власник будинку повинен теж брати участь.
Чи це фільтр в квартирі, і його термін експлуатації вийшов з ладу,
чи внутрішні труби, по яких проходить вода.
І там мають бути профілактичні,  санітарні заходи.
Що,на жаль,сьогодні не робиться.
Виходить, аби впевнитися в якості води, слід її перевіряти самотужки?
Тим часом лабораторія підготувала для DW аналізи проби води з крана.
Ми проводили аналіз на 50 показників:
це залізо, нітрати амонію, жорсткість
хімічне споживання кисню, гідрокарбонати, сульфати, хлориди, натрій, кальцій,  магній.
Також - на важкі метали, на пестициди, на ПАВи. І за результатами
бачимо, що у воді немає перевищень за цими усіма 50 показниками,
все у межах норми.  Висновок - що вода придатна для пиття.
Лабораторія, як і решта контролюючих органів, перевіряє якість води
згідно з державним стандартами, які оновлювались у 2010 році.
Цей документ замінив застарілий радянський ГОСТ
та містить максимально наближені до Європейського Союзу норми.
Однак для повної відповідності бракує ще щонайменше десяти показників.
Над новими документом нині працюють в МОЗ.
Вода з крана в Києві подекуди справді відповідає державним стандартам,
за якими навіть в сирому вигляді придатна для пиття.
Втім, аби впевнитися, чи безпечна вода саме в вашому крані,
одних результатів перевірки "Київводоканалом" недостатньо.
Навіть якщо на точці входу в будинок вода відповідатиме нормам,
вона може забруднитись через старий водопровід вашого будинку.
Крім того, з огляду на стрімку зміну клімату "Київводоканал" не завжди встигає
реагувати на сезонне погіршення якості води в річках
і доводити воду до контрольних точок у безпечному виді.